today i'm going to be speaking with
david livingstone smith who's a
professor of philosophy at the
university of new england
in maine and also author of the book on
inhumanity dehumanization and how to
resist it
i really appreciate your time today
thank you david
so to set the stage for the conversation
when we talk about
dehumanization and inhumanity
there are a lot of ways that we could
sort of define those ideas but what what
do you mean when you talk about that
well dehumanization is a word that's
used in so many different ways
i mean even in the scholarly literature
what i mean by demonization
is the attitude of conceiving of other
people
as subhuman creatures and
in history there are so many different
um examples of when we can say that
this dehumanization took place there are
times where
it can take place by people who are
trying to
uh justify horrible acts of violence
there are times when dehumanization
might even be
a coping mechanism by someone exposed
to extremely harsh or difficult
conditions in in some way shape or form
what are some of the different ways that
in human history
this has manifested well almost always
dehumanization is the product of
propaganda
so it's not something that spontaneously
arises in the human mind
rather it's the result of people in
positions of power who want us to do
terrible things to one another and the
paradigmatic example of that
is is genocide so if those in power
those who are in positions of authority
can convince us
that these others that they wish us to
harm
are dangerous toxic subhuman creatures
that we must destroy in our own
self-defense
then that allows us to overcome a very
natural
resistance human beings have to doing
awful things to one another
i i'm thinking of so many of the
uh books i've read about the holocaust
and concentration camps and the way in
which
uh concentration camp uh guards uh
ss nazi soldiers etc
um by by propaganda i mean quite
literally the story that hitler was
telling about about jews
and and about some others was about
these people
are not really human the way we are but
there's also interestingly
in some of the memoirs of survivors of
concentration camps
they said they also experienced the sort
of dehumanization even of their peers
which they saw almost as a survival
instinct
which which is is that a different
mechanism
well yes we'd have to go into some
detail about what they had
in mind but certainly people who are the
victims of dehumanization
are quite aware generally that they're
seen as
subhuman creatures i mean we find this
in the example of the holocaust
the two examples that i use most of my
work are the holocaust
which by the way has centuries
old roots in european anti-semitism
jews had been dehumanized since the
since the
12th century in europe
and also the brutal oppression of black
people in the united states particularly
in the aftermath
of the american civil war and in both
those instances the victims of
dehumanization
were well aware that they were seen uh
as subhuman creatures
monsters demons vermin
as a historical note uh what is the
is i'm curious whether you're aware of i
know of of uh anti-semitism based in the
idea of jews bringing the plague
uh and i i'm i don't remember if that's
13th century or 14th century is that the
earliest example you're aware of or is
there something
prior to that well well dehumanization
of jews we
find it sporadically earlier
so in the gospel of john jews are
described as offspring of satan
right so that's a very early christian
uh root of some anti-semitic ideas
right so if you're the offspring of
satan you're demonic yes
this idea of the demonic jew persisted
but it really took a terrible
turn during the first crusade when
christians marched off to to the holy
land to win it back from the infidel
and along the way they decided to
attack the infidel in their midst
remember jews were the only religious
minority who were permitted to survive
in europe
right um and it's from this point
onward that jews are racialized they're
seen as an alien and inferior race and
seen as
demonic devilish biologically different
even it was believed that jewish men
menstruated that jews had
horns and tails and and so on
and so it just picks up there and then
after the bubonic plague
of the mid 14th century
uh it it gets really really really bad
when it comes to the um
uh i i guess we would the dehumanizers
so to speak
sometimes words or terms like
they are monsters they are animals etc
are applied which in a sense is a
dehumanization of the dehumanizers
is the is that a pro is that something
we should be concerned about doing are
there risks
yeah absolutely we should be concerned
about that monsters are fictional
no one is a monster hitler was not a
monster i'm jewish i can say that
hitler was not a monster gobbles was not
a monster
these are human beings and it would
really benefit us
if we consider them as holding up a
mirror to what is possible
for any human being you know we are all
vulnerable there's no vaccination
against humanizing attitudes
is it uh is the term dehumanization
relevant to
i'm thinking back a few months now
during the coronavirus pandemic
the lieutenant governor of texas dan
patrick
gave this viral interview i think it was
on fox news where he said something
about
listen uh i i would be willing to
sacrifice myself i think grandma
or or so to speak something like that
they're willing to sacrifice themselves
for the good of the economy by which he
really met the stock market
is that a sort of dehumanization that
we've seen during coronavirus of
when you see a number 4 000 died or
three thousand died
and you just sat in your house and
worked from home it doesn't really feel
that that that difference of a thousand
you don't feel it in any real way
it seems like that's a form of
dehumanization some people would call it
dehumanization i prefer a
very fine-grained notion of what
dehumanization is
so there are a bunch of related
attitudes but you see
i think if we're to understand what i
consider
the most toxic form of these attitudes
which i reserved the term dehumanization
for
we need to get a good understanding of
how it works otherwise
we we don't have a chance in hell of
dismantling it
right so i call would call that
callousness
and of course what he's saying in fact
is he's willing to sacrifice the lives
of life of grandma
right grandma isn't speaking there are
are there uh things you've observed
during the pandemic that you would
apply the term dehumanization to oh yes
yes yes so
what's gone on in this pandemic as is
typical
by the way of earlier pandemics
is uh xenophobia so
the pandemic is is blamed on others
racial others because race and
dehumanization are very closely tied
together
and then when you start talking about
people
as diseased as dangerous
outsiders you are
either well on the way towards
humanization or actually there
you see it's it's it's not regarded as
especially acceptable to call
people demons and monsters anymore
so we have substitute terms they're
diseased
they're criminal they're dangerous
they're bad to the bone
and what we get in this pandemic and in
previous pandemics
is an upsurge in that kind of feeling
which has historically led to all sorts
of
of horrible things it seems as though
dehumanizat
the rhetoric of dehumanization probably
has some specific
overlap with authoritarian regimes and
authoritarian
ism is it can we can you talk about that
a little bit
yeah sure so there are two ways that but
i think the first question
to to address is why dehumanization in
the first place
and the reason i believe is that human
beings being
highly social animals have difficulty
performing acts of lethal or even
sub-lethal violence on one another we're
just equipped with these inhibitions
but those are very inconvenient if you
want to oppress
and exterminate others
so as i said
people in positions of power of
authority
can tell us you know these others they
might look like you and me
they might look like human beings but
really deep downward counts on the
inside
they're something else and that is
absolutely typical
of authoritarian going on fascist
it seems almost like a tool that's
necessary for such a regime
to advance its its propaganda to
you talked about the role of propaganda
and dehumanization early it seems that
for
for authoritarian regimes that
dehumanization of the other is
is necessary for them to advance their
goals it's certainly
extremely helpful i would say maybe near
necessary
hesitate to say anything is necessary
but it's
it is certainly it is certainly helpful
sometimes the demonizing ideology is
distributed through a community
so i s as i say in the first chapter of
on inhumanity i grew up in the deep
south
in the 50s and 60s and their demonizing
attitudes towards black people they were
that
was in the air you breathe a rush
limbaugh
say to propagate these things what what
how casual was the dehumanization when
you were growing up in the south
oh it was just it just as you know we
would say the sky is up and the earth is
down
black people who were not referred to by
that word
sure by the way uh were seen as
filthy subhuman
animals i mean that was kids in my high
school would brag about
hunting black kids with their bb guns on
weekends for sport
um that's that's uh and
do you rem was the was there a gradual
transition out of that that aligned with
the civil rights era 1964 civil rights
act what did it lag
that it it you know there's a gradual
transition but also re-entrenchment
i mean these things have not gone away
still
right we like to think about the new
south but these are
these things take a very very very long
time to change
right they they do not disappear quickly
they can remain
latent relatively invisible for
a long period of time and then the
social environment changes a little bit
someone in power like our former
president gives permission
for certain kinds of attitudes and bang
you know the confederate flags are out
what um where where do things like uh
eugenics and phrenology play into this
because on the one hand
you know stuff about measuring skull
ratios and all this stuff it
in a sense it's very human in that we're
looking at the minutia
of of the characteristics of the human
form
but the it's its use seems to be
dehumanizing
well it's it's actually a bit worse than
that so if we look
at the history of scientific racism in
the united states
during the period when these practices
were beginning to flourish
eugenics is a bit later but certainly
the skull measurement
uh work the premier
scientific authorities in the country
described black people as literally
another species they were learned
papers on on this and mixed race people
were seen as
literally as hybrids between different
species
so these see you see there the the
dehumanizing attitude is endorsed by
scientific
authority it could be scientific
authority it could be political
it's anyone who has that kind of
influence
right yeah i mean that that makes and i
know you write about this in the book it
brings me to the topic of climate change
and climate
science what do you see maybe to the
audience it's not obvious the connection
between
dehumanization the way we've talked
about in authoritarian regimes and and
so on
and the connection to climate change
yeah
well uh the the aspect of climate change
that's most salient for me and my work
on dehumanization
is that i think catastrophic climate
change which
i don't think anyone's going to do
anything about i think we're
well too late for that and there's
insufficient motivation
despite the fine words that are are said
is
going to create a situation which is a
perfect storm
for really dangerous
forms of dehumanization there will be
refugee
problems like the world has never known
you know when when the population of
bangladesh spills into india
um and
uh resources run short and
infrastructures
break down this is going to generate
intense xenophobia
and i would put good money
on dehumanizing rhetoric of the worst
most genocidal sort is the only way to
prevent it to prevent the climate
refugees from becoming refugees i mean
is it
is if that happens is there really any
way to prevent what you're describing
i'd i'd like to know and i'd like to i'd
like to think that there is
yeah we're human beings we can we can
change our behavior
uh but we have to know about it we have
to be aware of it we have to be vigilant
and there have to be policies in place
to help us and uh
i just don't think we're awake enough
to the possibilities to take the sorts
of steps which will be necessary that's
one reason i wrote the book
right dehumanization is an
ongoing problem and
to do something about it we have to
understand it
we have to understand how it works why
we are all vulnerable to dehumanizing
propaganda and what steps we might be
able to take to
at least constrain it the uh the book
is on inhumanity dehumanization
and how to resist it we've been speaking
with the book's author professor david
livingstone smith
uh an important uh topic and i
appreciate you joining me to talk about
it today
i appreciate you inviting me